sandy alcantara when he faced the
dodgers back in may it was well the
roughest start of his career and he
looks for a bounce back today in his
19th start sub three era sandy leone
sets up way outside and he gets lucky
bets to chase
strikeout for alcantara one away one
ball two strikes alcantara comes home
and bellinger hits a line drive base hit
into center
back to back two out base runners first
and second for will smith
and that is a called strike three on the
corner sandy alcantara with a couple of
strikeouts in the first
marlins go to work next
we're taking a look at julio ureas tied
for the national league lead in wins
with the cubs kyle hendricks not quite
as good the last month and a half or so
though with an era above five over his
last seven starts
18th start this year for urias
who deals a 2-0 pitch and this one is
set in the air that deep right field
jazz into the upper deck
good morning
well apparently the party's not over yet
it started late last night
some big swings to the bat
jazz was invited
446 feet
wow what a swing 30 year old having a
career year
pushes this one over taylor who knocks
it down picks it up and throws him out
stick-to-itiveness from chris taylor to
get cooper 4-4-4
well chris taylor never gave up on it
never gave that half step up and that's
what he was out by
that's a base hit past the dive of lux
and miguel rojas
keeps this first inning alive
a check swing but a strikeout
nonetheless
taylor down and that's three strikeouts
for sandy 2-0
ground ball
jazz gets to it gets up quick fires a
strike and that's out number two
young man can do it all we've seen him
swing the bat already today we've been
raving about his defense here on this
home stand
there's a bouncing ball to shore but one
of the fastest runners in the majors is
still doubled off
they had to be perfect then they were
locks to taylor to muncie and two gone
in the second he's got the weight going
straight at it which then just carries
his arm right into
will
smith's glove strikes out alcantara but
it faced the minimum with the help of
the double play ball threw a two in a
one-nothing game we are joined now by
martel gm kim aang kind enough to join
us for a little while this afternoon don
had a mutual option uh in his contract
and we've exercised our portion and
donnie has said that he wants to be back
so we'll be back for 2022. so we're
pretty excited about that one excellent
that's uh awesome stuff jasrado
jazz chisholm another 02. you got him
lefty lefty changer
since the double play ball last inning
julio is a different pitcher
he's attacking
[Music]
ten pitches ten strikes three hitters
three outs in this third one nothing to
the middle innings in miami
runner goes and that one gets away from
leon first base was occupied so
bellinger goes back to the dugout baity
gets to second
two out for taylor they'll contour to
taylor with a 2-2 let's hit up the
middle into center field for a base hit
marty's up with it here's his throw home
tails wildly up the line and taylor's
tied the game
with a two-out rbi single it's 1-1 in
the fourth this is that is a classic
example of what they teach
and on the 34th pitch of the inning
sandy strikes out mckinstry finally
started to put it right where he wants
it as this game has gone on the 1-2
fastball right down the middle and rojas
like a house by the side of the road
watches it split the plate
alcatel ready for his 98th pitch with
the bases loaded beatty hits a ground
ball into right field bases in the
dodgers lead
four consecutive singles and it's 2-1 as
baity drives home maria's
another change-up for a base hit
they chase alcantara from the game one
honor and run over four innings and all
three runners aboard his responsibility
still loaded here's smith
he lifts one in the air to center field
sending marta back he's at the track
he's at the wall to make the catch for
out number two
but it brings some mookie bets and the
dodgers lead 3-1 and a long sacrifice
fly from will smith taylor
hits it in the ground off the bag
it's 4-1
in the second with a double goes chris
taylor more two out rbis for chris
taylor
it sharply off chisholm
into center field
two more runs score
the dodgers continue to add on a big
inning here in the fifth
maria strikes out birdie for the first
out of the fifth
and his sixth k of the day
got him good morning good afternoon good
night for jazz chisholm
seven strikeouts for julio reyes is one
two to marte gets a swing and a miss
with a change up and gets three
strikeouts in the inning eight of them
told her today 6-1 lead to the sixth
right to the second baseman taylor the
data wins this one and keeps the dodgers
in front 6-1
100 pitches for the day here's his 0-2
fastball gets him looking
and a good stamp to put on this game for
julio urias he goes seven innings and
finishes it with a six pitch seventh
who's first one to rojas
he's pulled on the ground a third
mckinstra go to second one tailored to
first off line
two gone at the corners
it's been a pretty solid inning you're
not going to have three up three down
innings every time you go out there but
you're trying to post as many zeros as
possible still got a chance at that
strikes him out tied him up with another
slider
and he's able to strand a pair getting
this game to the ninth six one
it'll be their 10th win out of their
last 13 games
then it will move them back to within
one game of the giants as we head into
the final weekend of the first half
clevenger to duvall with an 0-2 to
strike him out and finish the day
finishing the trip five and three